where were you on july 4th 2012.
i was in geneva switzerland at cern the
european center for particle physics
research
but the vibe in the air was closer to
that of a rock concert than that of a
physics laboratory
there were kids 19 years old 20 years
old
who had literally camped out overnight
to get good seats
much like you would camp out for a lady
gaga concert except that
everyone had brought along their laptops
there were also
distinguished 80 year old scientists who
were jostling for good seats in the
presentation hall
but they were not there to see a concert
at all they were actually there just to
see a couple of powerpoint presentations
of course you know why they were so
excited to see some physics seminars
it's because
july 4th 2012 was when we announced the
discovery of the higgs boson
this was a massive worldwide media
sensation front page news on the new
york times
and newspapers throughout the world the
web servers that were bringing the live
stream of this
of the seminar announcements crash over
and over again
you may even have heard of a phrase that
physicists
sort of dread namely the god particle
the god particle was a label given to
the higgs boson by
leon letterman a very distinguished
nobel prize-winning physicist
back when he was trying to make the case
that the united states
should be looking for this mysterious
boson
but the problem was that letterman
wanted to give sort of a
marketing label to the higgs boson he
knew that if you're watching cnn and you
heard
higgs boson you would keep on going but
if you heard god particle you might stop
to listen
the problem was he didn't realize that
people would take him literally people
would think that the higgs boson
actually has something to do
with the existence of god that is
completely false
whether you're a believer in god or
whether you're not nobody actually
believes that god plays favorites among
the elementary particles
but the higgs boson is a big deal and
that is really what i want to try to
explain
part of the point of this course is
going to be not only to explain to you
what the higgs is
what role it plays but why people were
so
excited by it and because this is a
lecture course not a mystery novel i'm
going to give you the answers ahead of
time
this is the kind of subject where it
repays careful thought
some in this lecture going to tell you
try to explain
why it was such a big deal and then in
the lectures to come
we'll go through all the details and
fill in the story a little bit
so the point is the higgs boson is a
little bit hard to understand
because what we call particle physics is
different than what we actually think
about as professional physicists
i actually blame the guy named
democritus
democritus is an ancient greek
philosopher
he is really the father of what we now
call
particle physics we don't know what
democritus look like but we do have
portraits painted that are labeled
democritus
because since we don't know what he
looked like people like to paint
self-portraits and call them democritus
so you'll see pictures of people like
rembrandt with the label democritus in
fact we have no idea what he looked like
we do have a nickname that he got he was
known as the laughing philosopher
and democritus had the idea that you see
a bunch of things around you you see
water
you see solids you see air and the
ancient greeks would have thought these
were all
fundamentally different things the
atomists like democritus had the idea
that in fact
they were just a small number of
fundamental building blocks
that go into creating all of these
different substances
they called these fundamental building
blocks atoms
now sadly for historical reasons in the
19th century the chemists
got a hold of the word atoms and so we
now
use atoms in our modern language to
speak of the chemical elements
but these atoms that we have the
chemical elements aren't really
fundamental we know that atoms are made
of smaller things
what democritus and his colleagues were
really talking about
are what we would now call the
elementary particles
the fundamental building blocks of
nature and since the 19th century
physics has been trying very hard to
look for
to find the elementary particles
particle physics is a thriving field
we know that atoms are made of
elementary particles called electrons
they also have protons and neutrons
which we thought were elementary
turns out they're not protons and
neutrons are made of even smaller
particles called quarks
and we also have gluons we have
neutrinos we have
muons there's a whole zoo of elementary
particles we will be talking about
in lecture three the reason why
the higgs boson is hard to understand
is because particles are actually not
what the world is made of
we talk about that we use that all the
time and so when we talk about the higgs
boson it's a particle it's a boson which
as we will see is one of the two
major kinds of particles however
that's just sort of a sloppy
approximation to the true
underlying reality our modern idea
the idea that is really centrally
important to modern physics
is that the world is not made of
particles but it's made of fields
a field unlike a particle is spread out
everywhere
throughout the universe it's a number at
every point in space and time
a particle has a location but a field
is spread out everywhere and is
vibrating is changing its value
think of the temperature of the air in
the room at every point
in a room there's a temperature that's a
number
that's a field temperature is not a
fundamental field it's a derived
quantity that comes from the air
comes from the molecules the modern
point of view
on the fundamental nature of reality is
that
quantum fields vibrating at every
location
in space and throughout time are the
fundamental building blocks of nature
you may have heard the question is light
or are electrons
particles or waves i will tell you the
answer
they are waves they are waves they are
vibrating
quantum mechanical fields what we call
particles
are just what we see when we look at the
fields
that is the miracle of quantum mechanics
that's one of the subtle things we'll
have to describe during this course
now why is it such a big difference why
do we care
that the world is made of fields versus
particles well
like i said when you look at the field
you see it vibrating you see a particle
there
so it makes perfect sense to use the
language
of particle physics to say there's an
electron particle even though we really
know
there's a vibration in the electron
field
the one difference is the higgs boson
the higgs boson is itself a particle it
is a vibration
in a field called the higgs field but
unlike all the other particles unlike
the electron which is a vibration in the
electron field
the photon which is a vibration in the
electromagnetic field
for the higgs boson the particle is
beside the point
for the higgs boson it's the higgs field
that really matters
on that day july 4th 2012 people were
very excited to announce the discovery
of the higgs boson
but what got them excited was the
knowledge that there is a higgs
field that fills space you are soaking
in it as the commercials used to say
that is really what makes modern
particle physics
go the idea that everywhere around you
as you walk
through the universe as you wave your
hand through space you are
moving through the higgs field
now remember i'm saying that every
particle that we know about
is really a field of one kind or another
but there's a difference
between the other fields and the higgs
there's something that makes the higgs
special
what makes it special is even in empty
space
the higgs field is not zero if a field
is something that has a number at every
point in space
when you turn things off when there are
no electrons around
that's a way of saying the electron
field
is at zero in empty space all of the
fields we know about
are sitting at zero undisturbed except
for the higgs
field that is what is making the higgs a
little bit different
than all the other forces of nature all
the other fields we know about
the higgs is there lurking and affecting
things
even in empty space and that higgs field
plays two crucially important roles in
modern particle physics
one role is that it governs the action
of the weak
nuclear force as we will see there are
four fundamental forces in nature
there's gravity which we all know about
there's electricity in magnetism or
electromagnetism which is actually
unified into one force then there are
two
nuclear forces that only work on very
small scales
they are imaginatively called the strong
nuclear force
and the weak nuclear force all of these
forces are different in their own
individual ways
the higgs boson is responsible for how
the weak nuclear force works
and the reason why that is important as
we will see is that
gravity and electromagnetism are
noticeable
in your everyday life the reason why
they're noticeable is because they
stretch over long ranges
the nuclear forces on the other hand are
stuck there
inside the nuclei of atoms they are very
very
short range that was a mystery for a
very long time
why were the nuclear forces short range
even though gravity and electromagnetism
stretch out over such large distances
it turns out because particle physics is
complicated
that there are very different reasons
why the strong
nuclear force and the weak nuclear force
are short range
in particular for the weak nuclear force
the answer is the higgs
boson or the higgs field filling all of
space
the short answer to a longer question
that we'll get to later
why is the weak nuclear force short
range because the lines of force
that are trying to stretch from one
particle to another
are absorbed by the higgs field
that higgs field lurking out there in
empty space
is really governing how the weak nuclear
force
works and as we'll see that makes a
crucial difference
to how our lives work to how all the
elementary particles interact with each
other
the second main feature of the higgs
boson is that it gives
mass to elementary particles now
this is a bit tricky we're going to have
to explain this in great detail because
who says that you need a field or
something else to give mass
why can't elementary particles just have
mass
if you were isaac newton talking about
the mass of the earth you didn't need to
know about the higgs field you didn't
need to know about particle physics or
bosons at all when paul dirac
the famous physicist first invented an
equation governing the electron
he just put a mass in there he said the
electron has a mass we've measured it
i'm going to put a term in my equation
that tells you what that means
he didn't realize you needed something
called the higgs boson
to explain how the electron could have a
mass so in lecture six we will be
explaining
why you should be surprised that
particles have masses at all
and then how the higgs boson does the
work to get it right
it all comes down to the fact that the
weak nuclear force
is complicated people tried for a long
time to find the right theory to make
sense of it
in the end the only reason why the weak
nuclear force
works the way it does and the only
reason why we have a theory that
explains it
is because of the higgs boson so if
there were no higgs boson if there were
no
field filling space from which the higgs
boson arose
we would live in a very different
universe we would live in a universe
where the electron for example
did not have mass if you had a world
with the electron didn't have mass you
would not have atoms
because electrons would not be able to
settle into atoms that means no
molecules that means no chemistry
that means no biology or no life without
the higgs boson there will be a very
different place today we have a
wonderful
elaborate complicated theory of particle
physics
which also has a very boring name it is
called the
standard model of particle physics it's
an amazingly successful theory really
worth a tremendous amount of adulation
it's an amazing
intellectual accomplishment in that
theory
all of the forces gravity
electromagnetism weak and strong they're
all different
they all have fundamentally different
properties it was the higgs boson
that was the last piece of the standard
model puzzle
it makes the weak interactions work it
gives mass to some of the other
elementary particles
and was the last particle that we found
but because of the theoretical
superstructure
of the standard model we knew that the
higgs boson had to be there
before we had found it basically since
the 1960s
particle physicists had thought about
this idea maybe there is
a field filling space something that we
now call
the higgs field it seemed to make
everything else fit together
it seemed to make our theories of
particle physics make sense
all we had to do was find it and that's
what we did
in july of 2012 that's why
there was such an excitement in the room
in that lecture hall
at cern it was just a couple of
powerpoint presentations
but they were saying that we were
completing the standard model of
particle physics
we were completing our understanding
of how the matter that you and i are
made up
of actually works we're made of atoms
we're made of electrons and quarks and
things like that
the higgs boson was crucial to
understanding
how that worked as i said this
understanding went back to ideas from
the 1960s
and one of the most impressive things
about it was that these thinkers back in
the 1960s who invented
the idea of the higgs field and the
higgs boson
they weren't really driven by specific
detailed experimental results they were
really driven by
trying to understand how nature could
possibly work
how could it possibly be the case that
the weak nuclear force is such
short range this was a very difficult
issue at the time and it was
fundamentally
a mathematical problem we had good ideas
about where the weak nuclear force and
the strong nuclear force could come from
but they didn't seem to give us the kind
of theory that we really wanted
that's why we were eventually driven to
this dramatic idea
that all of empty space is suffused with
this invisible energy field called the
higgs
the issue was that we had this really
lovely attractive picture
for how forces of nature arise at all
we have these four forces why why are
there four forces
why do they have the features that they
do the answer that became
popular in the 1950s and 1960s
was because of symmetries again we'll
have a whole lecture
devoted to the idea of what a symmetry
is it's the basic idea that there's
stuff in the universe
and you can transform the stuff you can
imagine like
rotating it changing one field into
another
without changing the fundamental nature
of the object
that you're considering that's what a
symmetry is it's a change
that doesn't make a difference so we had
this brilliant idea from the 1950s
that symmetries imply forces
if you have the right kind of symmetries
these very powerful
symmetries which we're going to call
gauge symmetries
they give rise to forces of nature and
it's a very beautiful elegant compelling
mathematical structure
the problem is the forces that you get
out of these symmetries are always long
range they're always
things that stretched over huge
distances which we should easily be able
to detect
we found gravity we found
electromagnetism that wasn't that hard
but we haven't
seen long-range forces for the nuclear
forces those are only short-range
so it seemed to be a conundrum you had
this wonderful idea that you wanted to
be true
symmetries underlie forces but they only
give rise to long-range forces so maybe
that idea was not going to work for the
nuclear forces
the idea that then came along was that
these symmetries are there
but symmetries are broken there's
something in nature
that takes these symmetries and breaks
them just a little bit
if you did that then you could have a
symmetry giving rise to a force
but that force could be confined to
short range
and to do that how do you break a
symmetry like that
you need a field that pervades empty
space
and has a non-zero value that is the
higgs
idea in a nutshell you wanted to have
these symmetries
that give rise to forces but you had to
break the symmetry
and to do that you introduced the higgs
field
now when this idea came along in the
1960s
it was a very general principle it
wasn't something that was a very
specific model that was
meant to do one precise thing it was an
idea
if you have a field filling space you
can break a symmetry
giving rise to a short range rather than
a long range force
it took a few more years for people to
figure out you know what
this is how the actual weak interactions
of particle physics
really work once that idea came along
suddenly everything fit together the
experiment suddenly made sense
however we didn't actually see the field
we had that idea of the higgs boson but
we hadn't actually
back in the 1960s or even 70s seen
evidence for it in our data so the next
step
is to actually go look for it it's very
nice to have a theory that fits together
and makes sense
but we really want to get the direct
evidence that we're on the right track
and in particle physics that means
building new
more energetic more powerful particle
accelerators
really the way that particle physics
gets its direct evidence
is by e equals m c squared einstein's
famous equation relating the energy of
an object at rest
to its mass times the speed of light
squared now
you can think that the equation e equals
m c squared
means that energy is mass times the
speed of light squared but really it's
the energy a particle has when it's not
moving
what this does is it enables us to bring
into existence
new particles with heavier masses than
before
if we can squeeze a lot of energy into a
very tiny amount of space
so that's what a particle accelerator
does it accelerates other particles
to extremely high velocities so those
particles get a tremendous amount of
energy together
and then it smashes them together so
there's a lot of energy there you can
create
more massive particles it was really in
the 1970s
that the search for the higgs boson
began in earnest
the 1970s were an era when quantum field
theory really became triumphant
before in the 1960s even before that all
the way back to the 30s we had ideas
of quantum field theory but it wasn't
until the late 60s early 70s that we
really knew
this was the right way to think about
nature at a fundamental level
we figured out many of the pieces of the
standard model of particle physics we
knew that there were quarks
there were gluons there were w and z
bosons out there
we didn't discover the w and z's until
the 1980s
but we knew they had to be there even
the top quark which was hypothesized
back in the 1970s
everyone was convinced it was there and
we would eventually find it
and ultimately we did find it in 1995
at a particle physics accelerator called
the tevitron
the tevetron was a facility right
outside
chicago at fermilab the flagship united
states particle physics laboratory
and in addition to looking for the top
quark they were also looking for the
higgs boson
roughly speaking every major particle
physics accelerator
since the 1970s has been looking for the
higgs there was the tavitron at fermilab
there's a dedicated place called the
large electron
positron machine at cern but look as
they may
none of them were actually to a actually
able to find it
that led us to build the large hadron
collider the lhc
the lhc is not only the most impressive
particle physics experiment ever built
it is the largest machine ever built of
any kind
by human beings like i said it's just
outside geneva in fact it's underground
it crosses the border between france and
switzerland
it's a european collaboration where
other countries such as the united
states are sort of allowed to
participate but the u.s
is not part of the governing body that
really runs how cern works
the u.s tried to build its own particle
accelerator called the superconducting
supercollider
but congress canceled the funding for
that back in 1993
we left it up to the europeans to find
the higgs boson
so they built the lhc this gigantic
machine is
27 kilometers in circumference 100
meters underground
cost about 9 billion dollars to build
it's a lot of money there's no question
but it's spread out over many years
many countries and then finally in 2008
we turned on the lhc there were some
fits and starts
at the beginning we'll tell the
wonderful story of the lac being built
in lectures eight and nine
but finally it started running it
started running once and for all in 2009
and it got better every year
and finally in 2012 we found the higgs
in fact we found it sooner than we had
thought i was actually hoping
that it would be announced late in 2012
because i had a contract to write a book
about the higgs boson the book finally
came out in november 2012 as the
particle at the end of the universe
and i was hoping that the book would be
released the same day that we announced
the discovery of the higgs boson
but the lhc actually worked better than
we thought
and we discovered in july 2012. so the
bad news was
my book release was not timed at the
same time the good news was
i was there at cern i was actually able
to be there
listening to the announcements that the
higgs boson had finally been found
this was an historic event not just for
particle physics but for
human intellectual achievement people
were really immensely moved
by what they saw it was hard to find the
higgs boson
we knew from the theoretical construct
how it should interact with other
particles we knew how it should interact
with quarks
leptons electrons and so forth but what
we didn't know is how heavy it was
we didn't know what the mass of the
higgs was supposed to be
that was a what we call a free parameter
in the theory it could have been
a hundred times the mass of the proton
120 140 180
we just didn't know it could have been
much lighter than that except
we would have found it long ago so the
trick was to build up the statistical
significance
of the search as we'll discuss in later
lectures
all of these particle physics
experiments fundamentally run by the
rules of quantum mechanics
and quantum mechanics says that when you
do an experiment
when you do a particle physics collision
and you look to
see what comes out you can never predict
with a hundred percent precision what's
going to happen you can predict the
probabilities
of one thing happening versus another
one but you can't predict for sure
so what you have to do is do that
experiment over again
and over again and over again seeing
enough of an anomaly in your data that
you can say aha
there's definitely a new particle there
that's what took time
in 2012 but in fact the experimental
particle physicists did better than we
expected
they got the answer in july 2012
worldwide acclaim soon followed and in
fact nobel prizes followed for
peter higgs who the boson is named after
and francois anglair
another one of its discoverers so you
can ask yourself
why do we do this why do we spend nine
billion dollars building large hadron
collider why do
talented young physicists devote their
lives to looking for a particle
that may or may not be there many times
people want to know what is that going
to what are going to be the
technological
ramifications are we going to build a
better iphone are we going to cure
malaria or something like that
and the answer is you know when you do
this kind of basic research
looking for a fundamental new particle
of nature there will be
technological applications there will be
spin-offs we have done in building the
large hadron collider amazing
accomplishments in computer science
superconductivity cern the home of the
lhc
invented a little thing that we call the
world wide web because it turns out that
particle physicists need to
share data back and forth by spending
money
on doing basic research we inevitably
get
more back per dollar than we put into
the science in the first place
but that is not why we do it it's nice
to get spin-offs it's nice to get the
world wide web or better superconducting
technology
but really the reason why we devote our
lives and our money to something like
the higgs boson and the lhc
is because we want to know the answer
it's simply driven by curiosity we want
to discover
the way the world works we are driven by
the same impulse that democritus
and the ancient greeks were driven by we
want to know
what this nature is that we live in what
this
world is what are the rules what are the
ingredients
it's part of what makes us human beings
we are
curious we want to know we're not
content simply to exist and to live from
day to day and it turns out for particle
physics there is no
cheaper way to do it you can't say well
we spent
nine billion dollars on the lhc the
large hadron collider
what about if we spent only half that
four and a half billion would it have
taken a few more years to find the higgs
boson
the answer is no we would not have found
the higgs boson we would not have gotten
half as many higgs boson by spending
half the number of dollars
either you spend the money and you find
it or you don't and you don't
so so far fortunately the human race has
decided
it's worth the money to look for these
fundamental building blocks of nature
and the higgs boson especially is a
special particle
as we'll see in later lectures it plays
a different role
than the other particles we are made of
quarks and
particles called leptons we're not
really made of higgs boson it's not an
ingredient
that you can find inside our atoms but
the existence of that higgs field
changes the properties of the particles
that we are made of
and what this means is when it comes to
the physics
underlying the everyday world the
physics of atoms
and molecules the physics that underlies
the biology
that we're made of that describes us we
now have
a complete theory we have the standard
model of particle physics which accounts
for
everything that you and i are made of
it's not
all of physics there's many more things
out there but when it comes to
people planets stars anything you've
ever seen with your eyes or touched with
your fingers
we have a 100 complete theory of the
fundamental building blocks that make
that
up it's the underlying theory it's not
the theory of
planets and stars themselves when it
comes to complicated interactions of
many many particles
there are many things that we don't
understand it's as if
we have figured out what the rules of
chess are
that does not make us a good chess
player but still it's very very
important to figure out what those rules
are
when we think about atoms and the
particles that make
us up we know what the basic rules are
there's no room for new particles that
we haven't yet discovered
to play an important role in you or me
that is why the discovery of the higgs
was such a big deal
and now that we have found it we can
move beyond everyday physics
as we'll see there's dark matter out
there in the universe there's dark
energy there's the big bang there's
black holes
we're hopeful as particle physicists
that the higgs boson will not simply be
the
end of one story the standard model of
particle physics
it will also be the beginning of the
next era
in fundamental physics it turns out for
technical but believable reasons the
higgs boson is a more
sociable particle than any of the other
ones we know about
by which i mean it is easier for the
higgs boson to
interact with other particles we do
think that there are other particles out
there not ones that we touch or are made
of
but we think that there could be
supersymmetric particles there could be
extra dimensions of space
there certainly is something called dark
matter out there in the universe
we would like to see it we would like to
find it the higgs boson might be the way
to do that and of course the biggest
most exciting possibility
is that we will be surprised we have a
good theory the standard model
underlying what you and i are made of
but there's a lot that we're not
made of we have ideas maybe super
symmetry maybe dark matter
other things but in the history of
physics the most
fun parts have always been when ideas
have not been quite right
when the experiments have given us
something we didn't expect
now that we have the higgs boson that's
a tool
it's something we can use it's a new way
of looking at the universe
we're hoping to keep looking using our
new tool
and if we're lucky nature will surprise
us once again
[Music]
you